[Music]
is it okay that i don't really desire
any
new friendships because of how much i
enjoy spending time with my wife what
i've seen happen over time what happens
pebble by pebble by pebble their spouse
slowly over times becomes the person
they tell all their dreams to and all
the bad stuff
[Music]
what up what up this is john with the dr
john dolone's show the greatest mental
health
relationship
podcast on the planet
nobody ever said that except for me but
that's okay
uh evidently you can say whatever you
want on the internets and it's true and
since this is on the internets there you
go america and internet whatever it's
good to talk to you hope you're doing
well if you want to be on the show
give me a shout
1-844-693-3291 it's one eight four four
six nine three three two nine one and
why do we do this show
i
i don't want people walking around the
world feeling like they're alone
and i don't want people walking around
the world
feeling like they are
connected to a system that's hurting
them and i don't want people thinking
that they're the only one with these
thoughts or trying to come back from
hard things or in a messy relationship
or frustrated with schools or really
excited about schools or don't know what
they're doing with their kids
we just all feel alone and so this show
man we just want to walk alongside you
and um
try to help you make the next right
messy step and that's why we're doing
this man so i'm so grateful to be in
this with you uh let's go right to the
phones let's go to ashley and manchester
what's up ashley how are you
good how are you dr john good things
going well
yeah
uh my question for you today is how do
you have the
this is where babies come from with a
child that has been sexually abused
without it being a trigger for them ah
that's a good question so tell me more
okay so
um
our daughter she is eight
um she
was in foster care we adopted her out of
foster care um about a year ago she's
been with us for about three years she
was sexually abused by her bio dad
um so we've come come a long way with
her
but obviously those questions are going
to start coming up
um
and i guess i'm trying to just
get ahead of
um
what that looks like and how to really
handle that i love it um a couple things
one
thank you for
loving the kids in your community taking
one home
that puts you in rare error and i'm
grateful to have gotten to talk to you
today just you you've made my day better
just you and you you and your family are
incredible thank you
um how old was she when the abuse
happened
um so she was originally put into foster
care when she was five okay
like the
i know you feel this and this show's not
about me
the insta rage that happens when i hear
that is profound right
my daughter's six and so it's
i gotta stop catch my breath a little
bit um so daughter got put in foster
care where's dad now
um he is in prison excellent
way to go america all right so
that's just an aside so uh the date is i
mean the age is important for a couple
of reasons but
um yeah
has she started asking questions yet as
she started getting into some of this
stuff like tell me where she is
so
um a little bit just because my sister
is about to have a baby so it's brought
up um you know
i've brought up some questions and
like what's happening
so
has any of
any of your conversations about quote
unquote what's happening
um about your sister being pregnant has
that sent her into any sort of rage or
anger or crying or hiding or anything
like that
um
no okay
that's so here's
i guess with the conversations we have
had um i've more
just tried to avoid it okay because i
don't know
if it's going to be a trigger for her or
um
i guess we really haven't had like a
deep
you know yes age-appropriate
conversation yeah yeah okay so here this
is uh so glad you're calling this is
incredible i'm so glad you're calling
all right
so
what we want to do with her
is begin to here's what healing looks
like for her
that she can understand that the one man
on planet earth that was supposed to
love and take care of her
um stole from her
took from her right we want her to be
able to
have that understanding
and yeah also her body not take off on
her okay right
and that's the healing journey she's
gonna be on for a while right and that
will manifest itself in different ways
and i'm assuming she's in counseling and
getting the care and love that she needs
the
question was
okay
so we were doing when she first came to
us
um we were doing play therapy okay
which was great
um but then the counselor that she had
um
moved on and was getting a different job
okay and
um
they kind of the way they put it to me
was they were graduating her from
counseling okay hey that's actually a
good thing okay that means a group of
professionals looked at your child and
said this kid's incredibly resilient
she's going home to a stable family and
she at this time has
able to
she's able to handle um these thoughts
and feelings when they come up right
she's got a plan right yeah so
here's what we want to do with her and
with all kids quite honestly
is we want to teach them that their
bodies aren't weird or gross or somebody
else's gymnasium
and the way we do that
is by norming talk about body parts
about penises and vaginas and how they
work and where babies come from and
right all those things and so when if
you like
when your kid says how'd that baby get
in there and your eyes widen real big or
your pulse starts racing you're like i
don't want to say the wrong thing
your kid absorbs we don't talk about
that here
okay and or
how does that baby get out of there
and you instantly turn bright red and
you're like i don't know
yeah as opposed to
you have a vagina it's a special place
in your body that only
yeah the baby's right instead of it
being as though we're having a
conversation about a sidewalk or about
bushes in the front yard right
um right anything that deviates from
that kids are incredibly perceptive
about what mom will and will not talk
about dad will and when i talk about so
norm body talk okay don't be weird so
i'm saying like
don't worry about setting off a trigger
if a trigger shows up somewhere
um you'll know you'll know right and
then then that will be a conversation a
circle back with a therapist that says
hey every time we happen to mention
um hey you need to wipe when you after
you get done go to the bathroom which is
the conversation you have with eight
year old right
we go by the toilet they haven't flushed
and there's no toilet paper in there
right
it right
every time we talk about wiping
she smashes the door or she doubles down
the floor and starts crying that's going
to be a circle back that's going to give
the therapist some data until then
okay don't let them absorb one thing
about how their body is wrong or other
okay that's going to feed into the
original
violation which is your body is somehow
causes your body it's your body's fault
that there's pain that daddy's in jail
that you don't feel loved that you see
what i'm saying
um does that make sense this also shows
up with your other kids shows up with
your husband and you like just not being
weird about talking about body parts and
here's the magic here's the other magic
um when she's
11 12 or she's gonna ask questions about
menstruation and tampons and how does
that work and why do you have that mommy
just be happy just just tell her as a
matter of fact it is because it is a
matter of fact and we've become so weird
about our bodies right and yeah um
there is a book that my friend um i've
talked about on the show dr jennings
gave me
um it's i got a picture of it here and
we'll link to it in the show notes i've
got no affiliation with this book i
don't make any money off this book
anything like that uh but it's by julie
federico f-e-d-e-r-i-c-o
and the book is it's i mean it's very
very thin and it's just called some
parts are not for sharing
and it's about teaching little kids
some parts of your body are for high
fives other parts covered by bathing
suits are for you
you yeah that makes sense
generally you say
mom dad and doctor and that's it
in this case she understands dad's not
safe
right right so for this season it might
just be mom right you see what i'm
saying
yeah
um but having just this little book that
says yes some of these private parts and
then when you talk about because she
might ask you a question about
is that aunt so-and-so's baby still
coming out of vance so-and-so's vagina
she might ask you that at church or she
might ask you that in the store right
and you can say that's a private part
and we talk about that in private or we
talk about that we have that
conversation at home or we have that
conversation around the dinner table
right see i'm saying so there's a time
and a place but quite honestly we're
gonna let those things happen
organically because an eight-year-old
isn't gonna understand the quote-unquote
i i think the idea of the quote-unquote
talk
is
is not good because
kids don't understand we're having a
moment
right they understand
this thing got weird and dad got tense
and mom's acting strange and now we're
talking about this thing and i don't
know much but i will never bring it up
again right versus
yeah because if it makes if you make it
weird then yes yes maybe that's oh all
of my babbling just now don't make it
weird
all right
yeah and here's where this is hard for
parents
millions and millions and millions and
millions of us who are parents
didn't understand that our bodies
weren't gross or weird or somehow
to be hidden or shameful or
something until we were well into
marriage and we had to go see therapists
to figure that out right
you might be there and so you might have
to learn a whole new way of talking
about your body to yourself
and to your husband and your husband and
vice versa you see what i'm saying it
can be it can be weird because we've
never done it before
yeah that makes sense okay
i threw a lot at you tell me what you
think feel
no i think what you said
you know make sense let it happen
organically um and yeah just be very
honest and
try not to make it weird
have you talked to her about um
what her dad did have you all had that
conversation
yeah we have um which is
kind of hard because you know she
obviously if
she has obviously she knows what he did
was wrong and she's mad at him but then
she's also
wants to you know go see him um and you
know still
it's like a yeah i don't know it's a
weird no it's it
and that is the
gap that will haunt her
for a long long time right until she's
able to her little brain is able to get
some distance and space between her
feelings and the actual reality of
things
um because she's gonna start and if not
she hasn't already she'll start in the
next couple years
beginning to blame herself for her dad
being gone
you know what i mean like i shouldn't
have said anything i shouldn't have told
it's my fault that dad i can't see dad
right and he might even play into that
hopefully he doesn't but he clearly
isn't a person a character up front so
um it will continue to
be part of y'all's
conversation and she will end up back in
counseling just fyi she'll come back
puberty will be a whole new thing right
um but as we go there kind of what i was
wondering about you know because
as she gets older obviously things like
this are going to come up and you know
it brings up more questions and so the
challenge for her is going to be
delineating
she has to have touch moving forward
and
the person who's supposed to teach her
what safe touch is
violated that trust in a tragic right oh
ugly way so she's going to have to learn
that over the alarm system that her body
has sounded
right and that's just going to be the
magic of
therapy as she continues to navigate
this and you too you and your and your
husband the rest of the family
finding that balance between
no
like touches and it's not an important
thing it's the important thing it's it's
grounding for our bodies you have to
have it and somebody use that to hurt
you it's like water right you can drown
in water and you can't go more than a
few days without it or we die it's the
same thing right and so how if you
almost drown i want nothing to do with
water and everyone
how do you reintroduce that that's the
magic that we're aiming for here i would
rather you over
i would rather you err on the side of
um
being completely open with her when she
comes to you
and
norming
talk about bodies in your house
then adding another layer of
this happened to me and it's just not
okay to talk about because the person
who rescued me
she blushes every time somebody i ask a
question about pregnancy
see what i'm saying like and that
yeah i'd rather air on the other side i
also don't want you to take your
eight-year-old out for pancakes and be
like all right so we're gonna talk about
that's too young okay it's not too young
to answer questions it's too young for
the quote unquote big thing if uh when
she starts her period that's gonna be a
time when you all go out i want y'all to
celebrate that have a moment with that
right maybe get some other women in her
life that you can
say she's safe to call and she's safe to
call and she's safe to call
i think that'd be a cool thing right um
and here's what this means it's like a
it's a moment
but i don't know that
h eight's a little bit young to go all
right here you know what i mean to have
that talk i have had to talk with my
middle schooler
yeah
and i've talked about sex with my
six-year-old but when she brings it up
right okay that makes sense and very
age-appropriate
you know what i mean very
age-appropriate way and it's not weird
or it's not anything in our house so um
yes
hope that helps
man she's so lucky to have you
she's so so lucky to have you that
you're loving her and caring about her
in that way um
she's been hurt at the deepest possible
level
in one of the deepest ways possible
by
the person who could hurt her the most
and that that
pain that wound will linger for years
and years and years and years
and the only way she heals is through
relationship connection
learning what good touch is learning
what safety is and learning over time
how to regulate her body when it takes
off on her in situations
it's gonna be a tough road to hoe and
that's why
you and your family and your husband
y'all are incredible they are absolutely
incredible and i'm just grateful to know
you guys are out there
everybody
norm talk about bot it's normal sorry
we'll be right back
hey what's up delony here i've got a
word from our sponsor betterhelp i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at betterhelp betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing betterhelp is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
delony that's betterhelphelp.com
all right we are back let's go to chris
in my hometown nashville tennessee
what's up chris
hey dr john how are you i'm good man
what's up
uh so
i i feel a little weird just asking this
because i feel like it's just such a non
problem but
hey so listen don't ever feel weird
about asking questions man i'm glad i'm
glad you're i don't even know you're
about to i'm glad you're brave enough to
ask it that's awesome
i appreciate it so i've been married for
just over a year now
and it's been absolutely incredible i
really feel like my wife's my best
friend and i really couldn't have asked
for a better
first year of marriage and so
my question is just is it okay that i
don't really desire any
new friendships because of how much i
enjoy spending time with my wife
i just hear you often on this show
include having like separate friend
groups like going out and hanging out
with your buddies or going out with a
girlfriend that's like an ideal in a
marriage and
not only do i not really have that but
i'm just not really motivated to pursue
that like whenever i'm invited to spend
time with other people i just kind of
think why would i do that when i can
just spend time with her instead
so i'm wondering if that's an issue
that's going to cause problems with me
or with us later or if it's just like a
season of life that we're in and it's
nothing to worry about
i'm just i'm confused if that's
something that i even need to so dude
number one don't ever feel weird about
asking that question that's a great
question um i spoke about friendship and
love to 3 000 business leaders a couple
weeks ago
and
um
i got one negative review and it said i
don't need none of this crap and i
thought
man this whole talk was for you the rest
i mean every everybody else was escorted
through the roof one guy's like i don't
need none of this nonsense so let me let
me
let me explain it to you this way maybe
this will help
um let's say you've got your first job
out of college
and you um
take a job as a project manager first
job out of college at a teeny tiny
little company
and the first week you're there
the company goes public and raises a
billion dollars
and you didn't know this but
when you signed up for this company you
had 25 equity stake in the outcome
so overnight you're a multi-multi-multi
multi-millionaire it's incredible right
okay right
this job is so good
and you think to yourself dude i am 22
years old
i don't need a
cute little app
and i don't need a cute little uh
budget
i have
250 million dollars in my checking
account
right
i don't need this stuff
and
so you just go about your life
and you put a whole bunch of it in
bitcoin you put a whole bunch of it into
your friend butts um new business and
then you buy a bunch of speculative real
estate
and and so on and so forth
and then all of a sudden you look up six
years from now and the economy collapses
and you got zero
because you didn't save it in a smart
way and you didn't
you didn't continue to you have a bunch
of ferraris that you can't afford the
gas on and you got seven houses that
nobody can afford the rent on right so
suddenly you find yourself in an
absolute mess
and so other people are your emergency
fund for life
you have had a remarkable first year and
dude it sounds like you married an
incredible woman like high five to you
man that's so great and that also means
you must be a pretty incredible guy
right
you'll have something special and it's
wonderful and i love that and i want you
to continue to nurture that friendship
what i've seen happen over and over and
over and this is in the research over
and over and over and in the reality
is the vast majority of my
helping quote unquote helping folks
behind closed doors are people who are
leaders of things they run stuff they
manage things um
they're the big wigs in your community
and over time what happens pebble by
pebble by pebble
is they drown their spouse
in their friendship
they drown their they their spouse
slowly over times becomes the person
they tell all their dreams to and all
the bad stuff
and they tell all the burdens and all
that's good to share and be honest
but
man she can't carry that and the romance
and her own dreams and her all of a
sudden
um the weight of being with you is too
much that's why we are designed to live
in tribes and groups and people right in
multiple people who so that guy's got
the that guy's got the food she's got
the shelter
those three are taking care of the kids
like we're designed to
lean on multiple people
and you my friend are growing up in an
era where
um
marriage has taken on a new life it's
taken on a new existential weight
meaning
up until about 100 years ago maybe 200
years ago marriage was like
um for people to expand their empire
like they hooked their kids up for
political gain or for financial gain or
um like i was a peasant and um my wife
was a peasant and we're like hey you
want to do miserable life together for a
few years until we die
all right and what happened now uh my
grandparents were married for 70
something years
and
she thought he was cute and he thought
she was cute but
over time
they did life together he was in the war
she stayed at home they raised kids they
did life together and after 72 years
they were soul mates because they
they took the same breath
and what now what my generation and
younger we've been
sold a lie which is we're trying to
reverse engineer soul mate first and
trying to do life second it doesn't work
like that and so what i'll tell you is
this
cherish your wife
and know that the data tells me that
when our bodies recognize that we are
alone
that we don't have people in our corner
or maybe we got just one person in our
corner
it will sound the alarms and the alarms
over time
show up in the form of
dementia they show up in the form of
psychosis
of stroke heart attack cardiovascular
disease
you will die younger
is what the data tells me okay
so
you've had a magical year your job went
public and you made a whole bunch of
money i want you to steward that money
well
so invest in her
and give her a break
invest in you
make sure you've got other friends to do
stuff with that you can be open with you
can say is this wise or not wise and
then she'll become but a voice in in the
chorus that is the wisdom that gets that
walks alongside you in the world she's
not the only voice you're hearing does
that make sense
definitely so let me ask you this
have you always been a lone ranger just
kind of doing life alone or is this
relatively new or are i mean are you
married and you're like y'all are just
hooking up all i mean it's just awesome
year i mean tell me where you are how
did this happen
so i
have never had a lot of friends i've
never been a person to have a massive
friend group i've typically kept it to
like one to three to five okay really
close people in my life and i've had
that in every season in high school and
in college
and sort of when i really
initially when i met my wife those
friends that i had at that time i met
her in college and they kind of
dissolved away because i was spending
all my time with her and that
has basically been the case since
then we've been together now for three
and a half years and it's really been
the case does she have friends
she
it was basically the same way she had
friends in college that she brought over
from high school but
again when we got together we we really
ceased
so one new relationship one of my
counseling professors
told me something profound it was great
never thought of it she said most people
wait to go to therapy until there's a
crisis until it's almost all over
and she said how amazing would it be and
she said it's like starting a workout
program at a local gym
the day you wake up with the flu so
because it doesn't make any sense
she said if your marriage is perfect
that's when y'all should start working
on some of the things you would love to
see different
and so what i would tell you is this
somebody in your marriage needs to sit
down and it can be you and say
i love you more than
the the
the sunshine and the sky like write her
a poem i don't care but let her know
that you love her and let her know that
over the last couple of years
the intensity of your love has
y'all just kept rowing this boat
together and you've ended up on an
island
and the island's not safe for your
marriage because y'all are gonna have a
moment when there's a crack in the
every marriage goes through hard stuff
right
um
i've got one
i don't say this lightly i've
i don't know a lot of people has got a
good marriage as i do and it has
almost come apart several times okay
like almost like i think this is over
right
i've done stupid stuff
she's perfect and always and all that
kind of stuff because she can't defend
herself but
all that to say is
there will come moments that you need to
um you need outside support and love and
care and so there is no better time
no better time than right now when
things are great that you all say hey we
need to start doing stuff with other
couples
um i'm gonna get a group of four or five
guys we're gonna start i don't know what
you do play dungeons and dragons or go
bowling or go hunting i don't care what
the thing is and i we're gonna make it a
goal that we're each gonna have a couple
of people that we hang out with on the
side and we're gonna cultivate those
friendships and you're gonna do it
here's the thing even when you don't
want to
so
i have a rule
that when
my friend blake sends the text around
hey i'm getting the fights
almost always tonight the fights are
coming tonight y'all show up it starts
at nine o'clock i like to go to bed at
nine because i'm a nerd
and i exhale
and my rule is if my first thought is i
think i'm just gonna go to bed i have to
go i have to go that's the rule and
never not one time not one time have i
ever regretted not going and my wife
says
you are better when you are with other
people
the time we spend together may be less
in hours because you spent those hours
with those guys
but you were more at peace and you
laughed more and you were more present
with me and i didn't have to hear about
all of your conspiracy theories i could
just hear about two of them right or all
of you or whatever
please go get friends so let me tell you
this they answer your question
yes
you have to cultivate
connection and community outside of your
marriage
everybody has to have a group that they
hang out with and do life with and let
me be totally honest with you
since i started this job
i've done a terrible job at that
and now that my book is out the show's
doing great i am i've been all i've been
on the road and i'm off
now i've found myself oh crap i gotta
start over again i gotta find a group of
guys to hang out with and i can do it on
the regular and i'm gonna it means i
have to budget differently i'm gonna
have to budget my time differently all
here we are here we are so i found those
i must find myself with you chris is
what i'm saying and i'm committed to
going to make this thing right and i
want to challenge you and your wife
if you want the best marriage possible
both of you have to have friends we'll
be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why because
they're committed to doing what's right
for you and that means walking you
through paperwork that's way over your
head that means making sure you get the
right mortgage that you can pay off as
soon as possible and they'll try to
upsell you a bunch of nonsense that's
going to hurt you down the road and most
importantly when you're making this big
life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back so
um
preface this next segment with this
yes a few weeks ago i was on stage with
jocko
and i also
um
like hunting and i live in the woods and
i'm kind of a prepper
and i don't watch a lot of screen stuff
i do but not a lot
and i exercise and i like ice baths i
try to be tough
and i also have a six-year-old daughter
and
a lot of the times i watch not always
but a lot of times i watch it is
cartoons
and
like cartoon movies and things
one of the most so that's the preface so
one of the most common questions i get
is what is gaslighting like what's
what is it why what is it i don't know
what this looks like i hear it all the
time and now people are calling each
other gas lighter guess
here gas lighting is this gas lighting
is a form of control
where someone makes you question your
reality
right they make you feel crazy as a
means of getting what they want
so a good example is
uh you're with somebody in abusive
relationship and
a few months later
um
you're explaining this to somebody right
or you explain to them hey you hurt me
all the time and they're like i don't
ever hurt you you take things too
seriously
and
you just have really thin skin so when i
shoved you i don't i didn't push you
that hard i don't know what else
happened to you but i did not bruise you
um
or oh my gosh i told you that
that you looked ridiculous and
overweight in that dress you know i was
kidding
um you know that you're the one that
tells me that you want to lose weight
right gaslighting
it's a form of control whereby somebody
makes you feel crazy they alter your
sense of reality
as a way of getting what they want okay
so
what does that look like in real life
what's a good picture of that
um
there is no better picture i wish i had
a better one i'm sure there maybe exist
but i was watching a movie recently with
my daughter
and the movie is
tangled
right and here's let me set it up for
you
the young girl rapunzel got some notes
here is forced to stay alone in a tower
with a woman who's pretending to be her
mother
and who in reality kidnapped her when
she was a baby
she makes rapunzel sing to her to keep
her young forever and shelters her from
the world
sounds a lot like james's kids but
whatever this is two so um we got two
different clips spliced together here um
so yes as a gang we're all going to go
through a couple of scenes here in in
this movie tangled it's an incredible
display of gaslighting and i want to
walk through it a little bit
and also if you're listening to this on
podcast go to the youtube channel and
watch it okay because we've got it
spliced up to where it's great and
sarah's doing her editing magic there
but it's a great way to see it and to
experience it and if you sit on an
actual experience this
it i get enraged i get so frustrated
angry so all right so here we go nate
dog let's uh hit the hit the play button
and let's get after
by the way she's don't pull your kid's
hair by the way if you're watching this
that's just
that's just
101 don't pull your kid's hair
[Music]
hi
welcome home mother ugh rapunzel how you
manage to do that every single day
without fail it looks absolutely
exhausting darling oh
it's nothing then i don't know why it
takes so long oh
darling i'm just teasing
[Laughter]
all right
so mother as you know tomorrow is a very
beautiful look in that mirror you know
what i see
i see a strong confident beautiful young
lady
oh look you're here too
i'm just teasing stop taking everything
so seriously
ah that's it okay i had to stop it
i want to stop it like four times just
now
ah
and thankfully look at that look face
ugh she's actually doing that anyway
all right so i wanted to stop it like
four times already here's the thing
anytime you say somebody says something
to you followed by
just
kidding
that's a good sign that's an alarm
system that somebody's gaslighting you
okay
here's a rule of thumb for life and it's
an exhausting way to live
and it's uh
it's not always great
okay i'm just i'm prefacing that right
but gasoline's so prevalent in our
culture we approach each other with
sarcasm so much we we have no way of
entering into each other's spaces with
hey how's it going so everything's got
to be a snark about the president or
about a thing or about politics or about
those people or about you and your shirt
oh the nice shoes you picked today right
and i'm as guilty as anybody i just i
just i just did this with james kids
james has some
has four of the most incredible children
ever anyone who's around james's kids
walks home and with their head down like
they failed as a parent
they just do it's just the way it is
he's just a better parent than all of us
and
the way i combat my shame of my kids who
the other night we uh i gave them all a
bath then we had dinner and we were
quieting the house down and then all of
a sudden i look out the window and my
two kids are sprinting into the woods
one of them has a like a wooden sword
the other one's got like a shopping cart
and a stick like what it i think of
james's kids who are like yes papa and
then they go home and they like
anyway
i do that by i don't know how to enter
james of space and be like hey by the
way you're a great dad
that sounds weird
and like we're gonna hug or something so
what i do is i just make fun of his kids
right and then i go ah just kidding
and so i want you to always be weary of
the other side of a compliment
maybe weary is too strong but just
notice it
hey you do a great job
i just wish it was a little more better
or i really like the way you uh do the
dishes i sure wish
you uh
could care about our kids as much
a shirt man it's such a nice thing you
did for that person at church today sure
wish you loved your family that much ah
just just kidding just kidding boom
right boom
gaslighting is
almost
always um insult followed by just
kidding and as a quick aside
one of the most shameful moments and
this is me being like completely honest
one of the most shameful moments of my
professional career is when i was in a
counseling
this is when i was um at a counseling
conference
and the woman who was presenting said by
the way you know the kids can't um
process sarcasm right and i was like
excuse me there's a room of us right
there's a speaker
she said yeah up until about seven eight
nine ten um kids cannot process sarcasm
they internalize it
as fact they may laugh along with you
and i was like oh no
so i've had to shift if you are somebody
who's like
oh there's our little bottle butterball
or look how fat and rolly you are in
your swimsuit to your five-year-old or
four-year-old
that's downloading is fact in your
child's mind and they may look at your
face and mimic you and smile and laugh
along with you i'm just kidding you know
mommy loves you don't do that don't do
that don't do that to your 18 year old
don't do that to your 24 year old
lean into your children to your kids
or to the people that you happen to have
kidnapped and hid in a tower lean into
those relationships um straightforward
not with
just kidding all right here we go
oh okay
so mother as i was saying tomorrow
rapunzel's mother's feeling a little run
down
would you sing for me then we'll talk oh
of course mother
[Music]
flower gleaming glow let your power
shine make a clock reverse bring back
once it's mine do it has been heard
change your face design save what has
been lost
rapunzel so mother earlier i was saying
tomorrow is a pretty big day and you
didn't really respond so i'm just gonna
tell you it's my birthday
no no no can't be i distinctly remember
your birthday was last year that's the
funny thing about birthdays they're kind
of an annual thing
mother
i'm turning 18 and i wanted to ask
uh what i really want for this birthday
actually would have went in for quite a
few words okay okay rapunzel please stop
with the mumbling you know how i feel
about the mummy blah blah blah blah it's
very annoying i'm just teasing you're
adorable i love you so much oh my gosh
i was going to say how you're a human
but she's a cartoon so
i want to see the floating lights
all right here's the deal
here's the deal number one did i miss a
pause here
or did i pause too early jimmy
okay all right all right
okay okay a couple things here number
one remember i talked about how
gaslighting is twisting reality she
comes and says hey it's my birthday
tomorrow and she goes ah
no it's not and she's like um it's an
annual thing it happens all the time
nah
right that little bit of you're crazy
you're crazy
and then the mumbling and the insults
like oh you know how i don't like it
don't do that to your kids right it's
this
mommy's exhausted
your mere presence is exhausting me
and our reality is no i'm i'm i'm
bringing joy to the situation i'm
bringing
ah
just you exhaust me what can i
what do you need from me now the person
this this evil human evil cartoon
character has created a world where she
could only get the young girl could only
get what she needs from her and then ah
it's so exhausting that i've gotta help
you out you locked her in a tower
there's no food there's no water i don't
i don't have plumbing up there ugh i got
i got to pull your hair to get up here
right you've created a world that i i
have to rely on you
and then you make it a burden
this happens a lot in relationships i
don't want you going out with them i
don't like you hanging out with those
guys cool um i'm gonna get some other
friends that no no no no
you just need to spend more time with me
okay all your time with me i just don't
feel comfortable when you go with other
people okay cool
i always just have to do stuff with you
you just wear me out i just can't meet
the needs of right now we're into
gaslighting again all right here we go
[Music]
what
oh well i was hoping you would take me
to see the floating lights
oh
you mean the stars
that's the thing you're crazy
i've charted stars and they're always
constant but i need to stop it right
here
if you are in a relationship where you
are constantly the victim of being uh of
gaslighting
the links people will go
to not feel crazy
often include um no those are just stars
no actually i've spent the last few
years charting them
right
the links people will go um i would but
you just you're just overweight no
actually i've been in a crossfit gym for
the last four years and i haven't eaten
a carb and since 1987 right i'm doing
this work people will go to the ends of
the earth to not feel crazy
and a gaslighter will just keep moving
the bar and moving the bar and moving
the bar
okay
they appear every year on my birthday
mother only on my birthday and i can't
help but feel like they're
they're meant for me
i need to see them mother and not just
from my window in person
i have to know what they are
i brought
it's so hard
we cut the scene there it's so hard for
somebody who's being gaslit to actually
say this is what i need
this is what i need
and if you go back to the scene
originally this is just so hard for me
to watch because i deal with parents and
their kids so much around this topic
in relationships
marriages and dating relationships so
much around this
somebody finally gets up the courage to
say hey this is what i need
and a good gaslighter says
you don't need that
and because of the ecosystem that's been
developed the first per thought the
person has is
oh maybe i don't need that maybe i'm
crazy or maybe i'm a bad person or maybe
i'm evil or maybe i'm wrong or maybe i'm
a screw-up or any number of things
parsnips i'm going to make hazelnut soup
for dinner your favorite surprise well
mother there's something i want to tell
you oh rapunzel you know i hate leaving
you after a fight especially when i've
done absolutely nothing wrong okay i've
been thinking a lot about what you've
said earlier i hope you're not still
talking about the stars floating lights
and yes i'm leading up to that because i
really thought we dropped the issue
sweetheart all right remember i talked
about beware of the other side of a
compliment
now by the way i need to preface this
we all have to do better at accepting
compliments when somebody comes up and
says hey you're a really great parent
and you are say thank you and move on
don't be like ooh what's coming next
right but be wary of compliments
always be weary of we language
oh i thought we were done with this
i thought we agreed that we were gonna
have sex every day not just uh twice a
week i thought we
no we agreed on that right
and now suddenly
i'm feeling crazy on behalf of we
like i thought we dropped this says the
evil kidnapper
uh no this is still a huge deal for me
oh
you're a problem cause i thought we were
no mother i'm just saying you think i'm
not strong enough to handle myself out
there oh darling i know you're not
strong enough to handle
i know
declarative
is the third one i know you're not good
enough
i know you can't handle it
i knew you would screw this up
and a good gaslighter
preys on our deepest fears that were not
enough
that we can't
in this evil cartoon step
stepmother has gone too far all right
throw yourself out there but if you just
rapunzel we're done talking about this
i know what i'm doing oh come on enough
for the lights rapunzel you are not
leaving this tower
ever
[Music]
oh
great
now i'm the bad guy
[Music]
parents
how often do we fly off the handle and
then we look at our kids and say
look what you made mommy do
look what you were late and look day you
made dead all angry
it's not true it's gaslighting
it's a lie
when we
rage out against our kids when we snap
and yell at them when we act like
children
they don't make us do anything
we are acting like kids
we're acting like whiny bratty kids
and then we blame them for it and our
children spend the rest of our of their
lives trying to figure out
why they keep screwing up and why mom
and dad won't love them
it's time we take ownership of who we
are and how we act
so
the greatest
hope that was helpful for those of you
asking about gaslighting that's it right
it's the compliment sandwich and by the
way we teach that in business right if
you have to give somebody some
constructive feedback you know how we do
that because most of us don't have good
enough relationships with the people
that we work with
to say
hey i need you to be on time
right for real be on time
and i've developed a relationship with
james kelly the whole gang back here
when they say hey
do it like this please like i know
they're right and so we don't have to
have like a john you're handsome hey i
need you to be on time and i love your
shoes john like a compliment because we
have a relationship now we've been in
the trenches for a couple years together
now same with marriages right
if you don't know somebody you have to
come up with a scheme
right so develop those relationships be
weary of the other side of of
the
be weary of the other side of a
compliment that somebody's be weary of
just kidding
right
be weary of people who twist your
reality to try to make you feel crazy
gaslighting is abuse
it's dishonesty it's a lie
you're worth more than that we'll be
right back
hey delony here one of the things i love
about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show
your stories are incredible and each
person's situation is unique and for
years people from all over the world
have been asking if i do private
counseling or private coaching sessions
for them or for their spouse and as much
as i'd love to i can't realistically do
one-on-one coaching sessions with every
single person it's just not possible but
that's exactly why i wrote my new book
own your past change your future within
the pages of this book is exactly what i
would say if you and i were sitting down
together at a table looking for the next
right move for you to make in your
relationships or to help you live a more
whole and peaceful life as you read
through each section of this book i will
show you how to look and own the roads
from your past and head to the new roads
of a well life moving forward go to
johndaloni.com to get your copy today
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
i was singing this earlier off air and
kelly thought this is the great it's
actually one of my favorite songs of all
time the song is by the one and only
queen bee beyonce and the lyrics the
song is irreplaceable and the lyrics go
like this to the left
to the left
everything you own in a box to the left
in the closet yeah that's my stuff if i
bought it please don't touch and keep
talking that mess that's fine if you
could walk and talk at the same time and
it's my name that's on that jag so
remove your bags let me call you a cab
standing in the front yard telling me
how i'm such a fool
i'll never ever find a man like you you
got me twisted you must not know about
me
i could have another you in a minute
matter of fact he'll be here in a minute
baby you must not know about me i can
have another you by tomorrow so don't
you ever for a second get to thinking
you're irreplaceable
kelly and james tell me that every day
we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode hey
a couple weeks ago she started hanging
out with a gentleman from work and began
cheating on her fiance she wants to be
with him and i think that ultimately he
would be her choice but in order to be
with him she has to marry him now move
with him choose the military life for
the next three years yeah she doesn't
want to be with him she wants to be with
the idea of him basically whenever i
need to speak up for myself or perhaps
correct someone i usually have a severe
anxiety and get like a
fight or flight like
or freeze response who told you that how
you feel doesn't matter
[Music]